David is in Arizona
hi David welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
how are you better than I deserve what's
up yeah hey so I just wanted to get your
thoughts on whether that I should file
bankruptcy
I have seventy one thousand dollars in
student loans I was divorced in 2014 I
just get out the ball our divorce by
default mean I took no part in it
because of my Christian beliefs so my
ex-wife didn't get stuck with any of
that debt so I have seventy one thousand
dollars student loans about thirty and
thousand dollars in consumer debt I have
a bank repossession for my vehicle that
happened in June two knee surgeries I've
been kind of down and out I make about I
bring him about $28,000 a year and I'm
just kind of just like sinking I don't
know what the heck to do about this debt
all of its like in in charge-offs
letting most of its charges off I got
debt collectors calling me and I'm just
trying to figure out what to do about
this hold on forty eight years old I
have a fourteen-year-old son I have no
savings nothing and I'm just trying to
just rebound I it I got a business in
2016 and the horrible ideas the company
I was working for our body and I ended
up having to close it down the end of
2017 so they've just been kind of ever
since then everything's just gone
downhill you know and I look go ahead
when was the divorce 2014 in June when
was the knee surgeries the knee
surgeries I had one in June and I had
one in June of last year so basically
every last two years I've had a knee
surgery and I've just been I've been
rehabbing since then but I'm doing much
better now I'm back to working out he's
getting back in shape before the divorce
what were you doing for a living I was
actually a college dude now stuck need
to be engaging energy design some states
vac systems heating ventilation systems
and this kind of just working you know
our jobs in there you know what's the
best year of your life financially
income watch 2016 I did almost ninety
seven thousand not only on my business
and
out of the closure that I had a salesman
that was working for me that I wasn't
really encouraged to keep when I bought
the business and I ended up having to
fire him because he wasn't doing his job
which was pretty simply to go to doctors
offices and drop off brochures when I
found out he wasn't doing it I ended up
letting him go and he ended up taking a
position with one of my competitors and
just slowly but surely he ran me out of
business just drastically just dropped
off and it was kind of out of my control
because little did you know when you're
dealing with doctors life is a lot of
favoritism and who you know and because
he had been around for such a long time
he'd built the relationship so I just
kind of underestimated his his power I
guess well what I hear I'm just
listening to your story is an awful lot
of game an awful lot yeah a lot you've
been through you've been through hell in
the last five years a diplomat I might
earn a divorce a business failure two
knee surgeries and you're underemployed
making 28,000 just surviving and you've
been kicked and kicked and kicked and
kicked and you're tired that's what I
hear
am I wrong yeah and I've done it
stone-cold sober I don't drink I don't
do drugs I mean none of that I don't
when I was accusing you of hurting no
I'm just saying I mean hurts like it'd
been intensified because I'm doing it
like that stuff intensifies hurts that
you people think it masks yeah but it
doesn't you're much better off to be
stone-cold sober you got a better chance
of making it through this brother yeah
but I mean I guess what I'm doing is
giving it saying I if I were just
looking in from the outside number one I
think you would not be a human being
that was rational if you were not
hurting right now it's rational to hurt
with what you've been through in the
last five years I mean in five years
you've been through four major things
two surgeries a divorce and a business
loss this is a gut-wrenching behavior
series you've been there dude and if
you're not a psycho
you're not a psychopath I mean does this
knocks you in the teeth it really does
so you grounded yeah well that does that
because you find solid you know rock
bottom to solid ground but yeah but uh
so then what we've got to do is start to
rethink and reset and that to you you
know the rearview mirror is small for a
reason it's smaller than the windshield
and so we start to look out the
windshield and we say okay good news is
I got two new knees and I don't have to
ask a wife to do anything I'm 48 what do
I want to be when I grow up let's start
dreaming again and maybe we go back to
the engineering dream because your
biggest problem is not your debts your
biggest problem is your income and the
volatility of your income over the last
five years has been all up and down in
dipsy-doodle and you've been on this
whirlwind of crap I mean you just have
and that's all in the rearview mirror
now it should be your cold sober where
there is no vision the people perish and
so your goal your first goal is to get
your tank fill back up and start to have
something to be excited about again
that's in the future and that needs to
be around career somewhere maybe it
seems everything maybe it's something
else I'm sorry I'm a licensed real
estate agent I got my real estate
license in 2015 but I've never done
anything with it I've done a little bit
but beginning in the year I really want
to start pursuing the real estate good
okay why why are we waiting to the
beginning of the year well I guess
because I mean it costs money for like
other dues you know the association fees
and all that but I do graphic design too
so I've already designed a bunch of my
marketing material I'm just waiting for
the first of the year to release kind of
just a whole bunch of graphic design
freelance between now and the first year
yeah well I've done it before real
estate agents excute they don't like
pain I wasn't going to pay for state
agency said graphic design freelance
okay yeah you can jump online and get
jobs left and right doing that day
and just on the sides as a side huh so
let's make another twenty thousand bucks
between now and the other year you ain't
got nothing to do but work so go to work
yeah yeah yeah let's let's do let's just
generate some some activity and some
income but the only way to have the
energy to do that with everything you've
been through is to see something in the
future that looks like hope Hope
deferred makes the heart sick but when
desire comes it is the Tree of Life
student loans are not bankrupt able and
so you would be filing bankruptcy on
stuff you could probably settle for
twenty thousand bucks because it's all
behind
if you settled it all for fifty cents on
the dollar you'd be out so you know
bankruptcy is not really addressing your
issue you can file it if you want to but
that's gonna be one more negative thing
you have to go through and so I would
tell you to do instead is just take all
those bills and just throw them in the
trash for right now and once they're in
the trash then I'd start working on my
income put your call the student loan
people tell them it's on hardship
deferral had two knee surgeries a
bankruptcy in a failed business I can't
pay you right now ding ding hardship
deferral on the 71,000 the repos up
behind you it's done they're not going
to bother you for a while and the other
consumer debt you're not paying on it
anyway you got twenty thousand coming in
now you got a new side hustle of some
kind I don't care what it is but
something between now and then the year
go by make a whole bunch of money and
start clearing this debt up and then
once you get your income coming up then
we can attack the student loans and
reactivate them you can get through this
dude but I or I really want to help you
make sure that you and your pastor your
church community around you're getting
your tank fill back up and causing you
to believe in the future again because
it's a normal human reaction when you
have this many negative things come at
you it steals some of your hope and the
good news is is that you don't it
doesn't have to steal it you can just
decide okay I'm gonna look out there the
rearview mirror there's a bunch of trash
back there there's several car wrecks in
my rearview mirror but right in front of
me it's clean sailing I can start again
fresh take a bow
come back out for the second act time
for the encore career
you can do this I know you can't hold on
I'm gonna send you a copy of Ken
Coleman's book the proximity principle
it'll help you in this journey call me
if you need me brother I'm here